another world is possible if we come
together to understand that understand
the power we've got and Achieve that
decent better Society where everyone
matters thank you for inviting me here
to me I'm proud to be here thank you
very much from the highs of
glastonbury's pyramid stage
just two years later Jeremy corbyn was
forced to stand down as labor leader
following a crushing election defeat
the man that replaced him though was
Keen to keep him and his left-wing
support base on side Jeremy corbyn
made our party the party of
anti-austerity and he was right to do so
now Kia stama says Jeremy corbyn is not
even fit to be a labor MP he's now
barred from standing for the party at
the next general election and he doesn't
seem very happy about it
thank you very much I just want to talk
to you for 10 seconds about your futures
thank you very much
I'm Liz Bates and on today's Sky News
Daily I'm in Westminster asking how
Jeremy corbyn came to be kicked out of
the Parliamentary party for good after
40 years as Labor's MP for Islington
North
it all happened in just a matter of
hours at Labor's headquarters in central
London in a meeting of the party's
ruling body the NEC
I was hanging around outside with the
other journalists in the rain waiting to
find out what was going on
Luke 8 cursed part of Labor first a
faction of the party as far away from
Jeremy corbyn as it's possible to be is
a member of the NEC and he was inside
that room
this was a motion proposed by kirst
armor and it proposed that we shouldn't
endorse Jeremy corbyn as a labor
parliamentary candidate
and really we've had to go for this
mechanism because the question of
whether Jeremy is a labor MP or not has
sat there unresolved for two and a half
years
okay so just explain that because Jeremy
corbyn is a member of the labor party
and an MP but he's not a labor MP right
and this vote has basically said that he
won't be able to become a labor MP again
in the future after the equalities and
Human Rights Council issued its report
on labor anti-Semitism Jeremy issued his
own statement which suggested that the
problems of anti-Semitism under his
leadership that the scale of it had been
exaggerated and he therefore had had the
Parliamentary whip removed so he wasn't
a labor MP and was asked to do some
really quite simple things just to
apologize to say that he was in favor of
implementing all of the of the reports
recommendations and to remove a Facebook
post with a statement on it and two and
a half years later hadn't done any of
those things so we needed to resolve
this because if we if we didn't resolve
it this week it could have just dragged
on and on and on and we would have had
to take the same decision
um just as general election was called
which would clearly be a massive
distraction from all the other things
you need to do when a general election
is up and going a lot has been made of
Jeremy corbyn's reaction to that report
is this really about something else
which is that the party is acknowledging
actually that Jeremy corbyn was one of
the main reasons for the 2019 general
election loss and you desperately want
those voters back and this is kirst
armor saying to those voters this sort
of section of of Labor history under
Jeremy corbyn is over it's dead well
it's both those things so the the the
motion was worded more widely to talk
about the impact on Labor's electability
and you're right that I've had
candidates in key marginal seats say to
me that it comes up on the doorstep a
fear that the corbinites are kind of
still around and they can make a
comeback and has labor really moved on
as decisively as I believe that it has
in case Thomas says that it has but
anti-Semitism is a major component of
that I think it went far wider than the
Jewish Community I think anyone that
kind of cared about decency in politics
was was put off by it but if Jeremy
hadn't have spoken the way that he did
on the day of the EHR RC report I don't
think that the party would be in any
position to take any of this kind of
action he he would have been there he
would have been an inconvenient reminder
of a period in the past where we became
very unpopular uh but I suspect he would
have stayed on as a labor MP and been a
candidate at the next election the
culpability at the end of the day from
not being a labor candidate sits of him
does this show a ruthless side to kirst
armor I think it shows a decisive side
and a side that's not going to be held
hostage by people from Labor's recent
past who might want to hold us back I
have to say I've noticed in the way that
this has all played out some real
unsentimentality around Jeremy corbyn he
has served as a labor MP for 40 years
he's dedicated his life to the labor
party and yet oh thank you for your
service or it doesn't seem like there's
really even been any personal
conversations between him it's just see
you later and uh don't let the door hit
you on the way out people that are on
Jeremy's side of the party have made a
lot of the change of tone between the
kind of things that KIA said about
Jeremy immediately after he took over as
leader or during the election campaign
to become leader and where we've got to
now and I have to say I don't think the
fault in that lies with care I think
here instinctively did want to show a
bit of respect to someone that had been
the party leader before him who as you
say people don't have a problem with
Jeremy corbyn on the level of a person
that's one of the reasons why he got to
be leader because MPS who didn't agree
with him nominated him because they
liked him as a person but so the the
initial approach from Kia was very much
to try not to be confrontational with
the previous leadership or its
supporters to try to find common ground
to try to kind of bind the wounds and
reunite the party they tried to do that
and what we could broadly call the
corbinites immediately began to
undermine them and so he's had to kind
of get tough with them because you can't
have a leader that's not in control of
the party he's got to demonstrate to the
electorate and to the membership that it
is elected as leader Kia's got a lead
and he's got to take the party in the
direction that he thinks is the right
one for the country and the right one to
uh to get us it back into Power okay but
the local party his constituency in
Islington North say they do want him as
their candidate well we don't know that
the CLP officers have issued a statement
saying they want him but there was never
a selection process yeah I suspect
Islington North labor party has got
similar politics to the rest of the
constituency parties in in London which
is quite volatile and tends to follow
whatever the current kind of pattern in
the wider party is so I'm not saying
he's not popular the point is look you
haven't given them a choice we would
always prefer that members get to choose
but we also have to have standards about
candidates so that is through due
diligence on new candidates where we
look at all of their previous records
and check whether there's anything that
could bring the party into disrepute or
cost us votes in an election with
sitting MPS it's a bit of a different
scenario and it's and it's a completely
sui generous one with Jeremy corbyn
because there's a labor party member at
the moment he isn't a labor MP because
he had the whip withdrawn so we had to
look for what process we could use to
ensure that yeah all our candidates meet
a minimum level and being found to have
broken the equalities Act by the
equalities and human rights commissions
we've been found to have discriminated
against harassed and victimized our own
Jewish members this is serious stuff the
only other political party that ever
happened to was the BNP and we were
found to have done that under Jeremy's
watch how would it have worked if he had
been a labor Party candidate at the next
general election it would have been an
issue at every press conference wise
Jeremy corbyn okay what don't you care
about what what he did in the past okay
and just finally Luke we've seen labor
leaders have to deal with this many
times before Neil kinnick had to try and
wrestle with militants Tony Blair had a
clause for a moment is this Kia stormers
moment where he is showing he has taken
back control of the lake party well I I
think it actually happened a little bit
earlier than that I think the decisive
moment in the labor party turning round
was actually the the rule changes that
were brought in at the 2021 conference
remember that that the conference that
year was really quite finally balanced
it was the kind of final rear guard
action of what we could call the hard
left or the Culver Knights and they
thought they could trip him up stop him
bringing in the rule changes that were
required by the ehrc report and he
actually decided to be far Bolder than
that and bring in a bunch of changes
around the way in which we elect our
leaders and select our parliamentary
candidates and he put his leadership on
the line I think he would have been in
real trouble with um that hadn't been
passed and he he won that key vote at
conference and has really not looked
back since then
we've had enough of losing elections we
want decisive leadership someone that
looks like they can run the country in
an efficient capable way and
demonstrates the kind of prime minister
they would be with the firmness and the
good sense that they show as as party
leader foreign
[Music]
labor leaders who've ever won elections
all of the rest none of them were sacked
in this way none of them were treated
this badly unfortunately what it shows
is a level of intolerance of the left
which I think is going to damage the
party's electoral prospects this is John
landsman he was a central figure in the
corbyn project a left-wing campaigner
for decades he was behind the
influential momentum movement that
propelled their man to the top of the
party in 2015.
in 2015 people were desperate for Change
and Jeremy looked and sounded like
someone who actually believed in what he
was saying and was going to do what he
was saying you know he was genuine he
wasn't like on other politicians he
wasn't
calculating and you know he wasn't a
clearest he you know he he wasn't an
obvious leader and that was actually an
attraction for people who voted in that
election and above all they wanted to to
end austerity they wanted political
change and you know actually the
political agenda has changed because you
know austerity isn't universally
accepted as necessary you know people
understand that we have to you know to
get out of our of the economic whole uh
that we're in and to save the planet
from self-destruction we need
interventionist government so you say he
wasn't an obvious leader I think once he
was elected people maybe did start to
see that because he didn't always look
that comfortable what was it that made
it difficult for him do you think as
leader of the party you are constantly
having to make very difficult decisions
that's always difficult for leaders I
mean I'm told that you know it was very
very hard to make Gordon Brown Take
decisions and they had to have a very
structured approach to getting to make
decisions you know Jeremy was better at
evading them and you know actually you
need a leader to manage his team and you
know the the result was that you had in
fighting in the team in the leader's
office that wasn't a clear sense of
direction and I think that was reflected
in the messaging in the 2019 election
which was a bit all over the place it
was very badly run and that was down to
uh you know a leader that wasn't you
know driving the team and you know that
isn't what Jeremy does actually I mean
he's a I think a very very principled
very moral you know which I think is
seen by labor party members and people
who voted militia elections very
desirable characteristics they respond
emotionally to that but it isn't
probably the most important thing to
lots of Voters they want to know what
what it's going to do for them and I
don't think Jeremy always got his
message across have you spoken to Jeremy
corbyn at all in the past few days I
haven't spoken to him it is not for many
not for many months actually what do you
think you should do now well I
he's got to make his own decisions this
is a you know free country uh we have a
liberal democracy he can stand as an
independent if he wants to I hope he
won't uh because I don't think that's
what in the B is in the best interests
of the left or of the politics that
Jeremy corbyn supports actually so I
mean it I understand his loyalty to
Islington
uh you know I you know he's he's turned
around the very small majority that he
had when he was first elected 40 years
ago uh into a very substantial majority
but you know I think he would have a
much stronger voice as a former labor
leader who was still a labor party
member than as a as a solitary back
bench MB and so I think that uh he
should do what Tony Ben did and uh leave
Parliament at the next election to make
more time for real politics do you think
you would have a chance of winning well
I don't know I mean I don't think you
can ever take these things for
us for very strong
strong seen as being
as being a very good effective
constituency MP but this is an issue
about the future of the party actually
this isn't about Jeremy corbyn Jeremy
has resigned as leader he's not going to
be leader again and what we on the left
of the labor party need to do to advance
are thinking you know and and put that
that into practice have some hope of
putting that into practice is to have a
strategy that will work you know for the
party as a whole we want we all want I'm
sure Jeremy corbyn wants a labor
government even if he was elected
independent he's not going to vote to
put the Tories in but we need to work
together to get that labor government
but also to influence its direction so
that it actually it does you know come
forward with the policies that we need
to resolve our terrible problems we
don't want to see the left abandon the
party because
they need to steer it in the right
direction right look we have a first
past the post system personally I'm in
favor of proportional representation so
you know but when you've got a first
pass the post system you've got a
two-party system yeah there's you know
it's the tour is all labor that's the
those are the only real choices of the
next election I want a labor government
not a Tory government I want any labor
government I wanted the black government
to to win too and I wasn't you know I I
felt much more disillusioned by the
policies that Blair was advocating uh at
the only of course but I of course I
wanted to see a labor Victory I think
Blair had a chance to get rid of Corbin
didn't he chosen up to it's quite
interesting but there was one more thing
I wanted to ask you it was never as
ruthless as as Kirsten
and he was was undoubtedly a much more
effective prime minister I didn't agree
with everything he did of course
certainly not going to war in Iraq but
he was a very effective leader I think
care has yet to prove itself sometimes I
think
we very easily forget in politics that
politicians are also people you know
Jeremy corbyn how do you think all this
will affect him well I I think it is a
completely unfair personal attack on him
you know the truth is he didn't really
want to be leader you know he didn't
expect to be leader no one did if anyone
if people had thought that he might
become leader he wouldn't have got the
bat on the ballot paper you know he had
a grueling five years as a leader it was
very very challenging for him I feel you
know I felt for him personally through
that you know it wasn't really what he
wanted to do and he didn't have all of
the qualities that you need to be a
leader of the labor party or prime
minister I mean no one has all of them
but to kick you know it feels like he's
being kicked when he's down you know he
lost the election he has to live with
that you know to kick him when he's down
is just an indefensible
he may be down but he's certainly not
out yet still with huge numbers of loyal
supporters they're Keen to see what
Jeremy corbyn will do next As for kirst
armor he'll be hoping this newfound
ruthlessness will be enough to get him
into number 10.
[Music]
my thanks to John landsman and to Luke
akhurst and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Liz Bates
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett our editor was Philly Beaumont